ten years ago we started a website
called Himalayan org we have now and we
have that is at of our foundation on
seventeenth Street we have three
full-time people it's been in existence
for 10 years and we have somewhere
between thirty and forty thousand pieces
of art on the website most of them with
descriptions we have the collections
from the Met and Natural History and
sackler and Boston and Philadelphia fine
arts collections on the web and many
many museums and we are in the process
of working with museums to give us
images electronically for us to put on
and a lot of the images that are on we
have scholars that work on dating them
describing them and you might want to
look at that website because I think
it's very important you might even want
to bring it up on your screen if you if
you have that's one we do the other one
we have in that's in my office on 17 117
the other one we do there is a website
that we we have probably provide after
funding for tibetan buddhist research
center headed by Gene Smith and we
provide free free rent and services for
him for many many years he has 10
full-time people working with him and he
is the most important Buddhist scholar
in the world with literature manuscripts
and he has this website that has all
these manuscripts on on a website so
that they could be looked at and in the
monasteries in the schools and you can
do it everywhere
you